So one of my goals for 2024 is less impulse shopping.
So instead of shopping less,
we're shopping bigger,
which simply means investing in higher quality pieces,
but a whole lot less of them.
And really trying to, like,
fill gaps in my wardrobe
that I want to purposefully fill,
as opposed to just
impulse buying something because it looks cute.
Because, like,
a lot of stuff looks cute.
So here is my little shopping vision board.
Um, I've got this polka dot dress from
the Pretty Dress Company.
It's on pre order.
I've actually already pre ordered this,
and I'm really excited about it
because I need a black and white dress.
I love a polka dot,
and I love this company.
Also have this dress by Mila.
Mila, I think is the name of the brand.
Here's a close up of it.
The silhouette,
the color, the shape.
I. Ugh, love it.
I have been wanting to get a vintage
Lily Anne coat forever,
either in a style like this with, like,
the fur at the top,
or the classic,
like, dress coat.
If you're a vintage collector,
these are like creme de LA creme.
Also currently obsessed with this handbag,
and I'm wearing the perfect headband for it.